[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
joe vardon joins us joe we didn't get to
hear your question what was your
question to greg popovich
well hi dan good to see you as always um
my question was not to greg popovich it
was to damien lillard
uh and essentially i asked him what it
was like for him
to have to to having uh watched
his colleagues in 14 and 16
uh blow these teams out roll through
these tournaments go undefeated
and then now getting into olympic play
and and having to experience the other
side of it
and dame actually gave a thoughtful
answer he talked about how this was
this was very different um acknowledging
watching those
those blowouts and all those wins but
then he said you know i've also seen
team usa be challenged in the past maybe
not lose two in a row
um and then you know greg jumped in
uh and and and started to address uh
me and and the question that that was
not directed at him
um and it goes back to a much calmer i
guess
exchange not not that that was um you
know wild or anything last night but
a much calmer exchange we had after
nigeria
when i was asking about basically
american exceptionalism
when it comes to basketball after you
know they had just gone through what was
arguably the
the largest upset in international
basketball history uh the spread was 29
points
and uh just asked what this meant to him
um but dame lillard wasn't available uh
after that nigeria game and so
you know and they didn't practice the
next day so there's no media available
ability then so this was our one bite at
the apple to ask other players what this
is like
um and then coach jumped in and uh
started you know down that path but
so you're trying to interject something
what what what is he having a problem
with
with you trying to interject well i've
been
covering this team um i keep saying for
two summers right because we
everything of course was was interrupted
last year
um but he's been he has been saying over
and over that
you know the world's gotten better which
is true there's more pros on all these
teams which is true
um but he's saying as we heard in the
clip that
that it is not true uh that there that
in the past there were all these
blowouts and it's it's right there dan
in the game notes
uh in the wonderful game notes written
by team usa
pr director craig miller the average
margin of victory
uh in the 2016 olympics was like
30 29 or 30 and then in the 14
fiba world cup it was like 29 30
32 somewhere in there uh and then
in the 2016 gold medal game team usa
literally beat serbia by 30 points
and that's what i was saying like he
started down that path again and like
you know because not everybody's
watching every
interaction we have but he was saying
something
that just isn't altogether accurate
and and he was going to use it i think
to make a point and so i was just saying
no that's not true uh
and i i tried to say to bring up the
thing about the the average margin of
victory and
you know but i i know it didn't get
picked up
what is the level of concern for this
team
so we're trying to figure that out um
you know the latest thing is that
they're saying that well
you know our guys aren't in shape which
is apparent you know for instance
bradley beal was was standing you know
doubled over at one point last night and
and they haven't been good late in the
fourth quarter
um which suggests to a condition a
conditioning issue
but you know five of their seven
rotation players played at least one
round the playoffs
and and a couple of them went into the
second round so
i don't know if i i don't get that and
into a larger degree like
australia is in shape and nigeria's in
shape but team usa is not in shape
yeah so so that one's a problem um but
okay
to answer your question how big is the
concern i mean
there are i guess questions about the
roster like
it's a smaller team uh it's a team
that's supposed to score a ton of points
um you know they're getting killed on
the glass right now
and uh they are being exposed uh
defensively
but you know in teams past like if if
there was a maybe a small liability here
there
you know the americans have been so
mighty overall that
that you could they just sweep past that
and for for a reason that we don't know
yet the margin of error has shrunk
dramatically
so when you say how much concern is
there
i think we've reached a point where the
americans could
win the gold medal and and they might
very well but but we actually don't know
and i think that's the first time in
quite a while
um in an olympics uh setting that we can
say that so it's either going to be a
really exciting tournament or a really
nerve-wracking tournament depending on
your point of view
biggest threat to the united states in
the olympics is who
i don't know that you can say any one
particular team i mean they open up
against france
who already beat them uh in the in the
china
world cup two years ago that's a tough
one
um but you know
this is the kind of team that on a on a
bad night luca doncic
and the other four slovenians could just
show up and beat them i mean luca could
go off for 50
uh and do what he's done to the clippers
and you know in one game it's not a
seven game series so
i think there are threats throughout
this tournament um we'll see how much
better they get when the three guys who
are in the finals
join up and um and i and i do think
kevin durant
you know needs to find his legs a little
bit because he's getting good shots
he's 10 of 30 in two games um you know
so i think
when he gets to be uh start knocking
some of those down we'll start to see
the results flip but again
the margin of error is almost almost
gone
which is remarkable joe i was surprised
that durant played
um for the olympics um i don't know if
he needs more playing time or needs more
rest given what he just went through
and what he did a herculean task in the
playoffs how surprised are you that
durant is playing yeah i was i was
shocked
and um i wrote about this in the in the
run-up to
the start of exhibition play in the
early part of camp um
i think obviously you're surprised i'm
surprised most the people who do our
jobs are
are surprised um but the people who know
kevin
just talk about like this sort of um
single affinity for the game and i know
it's a cliche like oh i love the game
but i think he actually kind of lives it
and i also think that
what has happened to him over the last
couple years with these terrible
injuries
his has sort of driven home the point of
wanting to do
everything he can while he still can so
you know assuming this tournament turns
around and they they right the ship
um kevin will probably go down as the
greatest uh
american olympic basketball player which
is i don't know if he cares about that
kind of stuff but it's it's
gonna be uh something that that goes to
him
steve keep mixing it up there joe we we
appreciate your time
thanks for joining us thanks for having
me all right that's uh joe vardon
he's a senior nba writer for the
athletic covering team usa at the
olympics team usa
loses to nigeria loses to australia and
they've got argentina coming up tonight